[Music]
we title and then their title is done
safely streamlining healthcare policy
management using ideas from structure
here and so the point health is a
company that provides a platform for our
players we offer enough care to the
workhorse and what that means is that we
have a couple of different parts of the
platform and one thing you can see in
images into there's a cell phone app and
there's learning portals that are used
for the people who earned workforce to
find and get care get their medical
cards and basically manage all the parts
their transplant there's also a separate
website excuse by these players and you
can see that there's example the kind of
benefits page that would explain to
somebody who's got a medical plan with
their benefits are in this case it's a
attorney benefit so somebody who's
pregnant you know I don't care they get
for the preventative care and so far
there's also a fairly large back-end the
whole business review process all the
medical claims all the dependable
efficient pharmacy claims and we also
handle phone support so objectively the
company is the brand better member
experience and using kind of Gator we've
had some pretty good success we've been
in business for a few years of logic our
major platform to 16 and they're here
right now the only plan we've shown that
the medical trends there have been
pretty flat and we didn't have really
big response from earth and personal
terms of customers so the basis of the
whole thing is really is I need the
health plan and something
to talk about certainty doesn't all
these plans around and kind of manage
them in streamlining engineer them and
so first questions of when's the health
plan plans that fairly complicated thing
basically there's always you know many
many detailed hypothetical situations of
mental situations are different types of
services that would come up in terms of
getting preventive care like flu shot or
actually broke your leg or you get it
becomes like a bees or whatever there's
lots lots of different conditions there
and then there's also many many
different hypothetical states that
personal convenient they can have just
had what's called a basically a
qualifying event let's say they just
married and that means they can change
their plan they can be a moment in which
case they you know sign up for a plan or
they can be been here it can actually
you know different person very
comfortable and so the question is who
can fly them to what conditions there's
lots and lots of pages of text that are
companies you think that's assignment
lot here the different sizes and health
care documents and so this is the long
bottle y-axis and you can see that these
are all different types of documents
that are involved with one of our health
plans of the first five rooms are
basically different types of documents
that are entitled plan with a pool of
about 150 pages of text that are
required to define the health plan and
so there's a comparison
one-third the size of the novel doctor
zhivago
right so is a huge lot of text desk
require to define an on plan you know we
actually serve lots of notes that health
plans because you know number of
customers each which has many plans so
we never want 10,000 teaches the text
total and so in the text document
there's actually a lot of into
consideration started mentioning
considerations financial legal and
ethical considerations are all
requirements in to be there in the plan
and there's lots of dialects of you know
formal dialects of
these deliveries reporting dependents
consider so you know it's actually a
very manual process right and so how do
we feel like we want to you know it's
nice to you but I actually figure out at
school and so what we want the more I
have seen through peel p50 through peel
first of all as a diplomat also I knows
many many languages so there's been you
say 30 mm diam excellent health care
that sees people get help
the coroner's talk to the policymakers
talk to the vision it's good so what
they don't have super together we have
an amount of text and we have some ideas
around process automation so there's
business process automation and there's
like that medicine and you know my house
combination where you basically build
you know macros and scripts to help
thread together different tools that are
used processing there's a weaker the
subject of this pop is the interview
ideas for language processing to enhance
this whole procedure and make it you
know get us to an intelligent version
across our nation that understands what
it's doing and there are lots more so
one of the key ideas here is that as we
had more automation at the system we
want things to be safe and so in a way
we think about how to make things safe
let to sort of look at how to was the
cross seas around building nuclear power
plants right and so in those types of
situations not made creation is actually
a really big deal and so here they have
cyber departments and my sister
departments which other in terms of what
you hired to be there to make sure that
they're so they safe and those are have
to be communicated to both the design
process and the databases associative
building the plan and actually also
implementation on actually building plan
and all those three things have to be
kind of conforming right and so there
was if you actually thought for building
one thing maybe build a different thing
it can be pretty dangerous and this so
how do we apply that healthcare oh you
know so and Symantec so if the system
allows us to build tools that remind
automation and safety in denouncing it
and so when we move my safety
there's four things first of all what
I'm peer review and approval of updates
you want to have the ability to track
recover I think it's done in its plan
spike did it and we want to have a
checking and verification of all these
things and we want to be resilient so
that those are the forehead colors of
safety and when you have kind of areas
where the health plan is defined
differently in different places you can
have a lot of miscommunication actually
a lot of headaches in terms of people
thought they were going to be covered in
an operation maybe they weren't or
whatever and that's actually a big deal
so we want to avoid that and so so I'm
going to Halloween thought about
bringing the ideas of natural language
and and language processing into this so
you can see this is a first time that
page where website defines the refirming
benefits which is kind of a way of
describing some of these what someone's
policy is in this case if someone's
pregnant preventive care is actually
free if it's in an in-network case then
it's not covered out of network so the
natural language version of this is for
preventive care attorney benefits in
network visits and a zero dollar
campaign and I've never visits about
card so there's some keywords in there
from advocator maternity Sarah dollar
copay and not covered and then there's
some contacts that's very healthcare
specific so probably most of you who
have health insurance know what a
network is and what network means and
network means that your patient's
provider it has a relationship with that
doctor therefore it you certainly
remember so there's a big difference if
you could talk to this out of network
and you might pay for it yourself up and
down it so you know that that actually
there is already kind of something that
not everybody wants to read every day
right so the way that we started looking
at domaine de more manual for the people
who are dealing with in the back office
and this is also very
or the practices they down is this I
need my tabular structured national
languages so what that means is that the
parsing of the language is actually done
graphically
sending out into different categories so
here there's code a category service
right and then different conditions in
terms a in an our network coverage and
so those key words that I bought for the
top each map to one of these columns and
you can go back and forth it's a little
bit more you can go from natural
language to the tabular natural language
but in fact you can actually go back and
forth between these two different types
of life and then moving on with the
structured language which is probably
something that you look silly when you
can take something like this time
whenever language and then with the
transformation turn it into a serialized
object in this case the JSON object
so all the seeing information that is in
the tabular chirp language can get the
JSON object and then it's on there that
can be used in program so that's the
guts of the three components of ways
that the information is stored and I've
sort of put it into a diagram and you
can see the bed blocks of those three
blocks there's the structured language
at the bottom there's this country
naturally know which is that tabular
structure of language and then there's
natural language is the and then so
those are the three categories no I
thought it was arrow this mature capsule
missing pieces and they're documented so
there's pretty kind of key ideas and the
plane be possible any event described
versus parsing which basically means
you're reading constructing options and
then there's another idea collapsing
which is kind of a subset of parsing
which go cognizes verbs in a minute
strip and the third thing is rendering
which is actually basically so going
from the structured language to the
tabular version requires the parser so
it's actually going to sort of DC
Airlines
object from that casement structure is
going to kind of map it into this this
structure and they need some context to
do that in the context this conflict in
our case would call them at just best
play out further and then there's a
second operation taking it to natural
language where it's already the words
are already kind of set out so the
person you have to take it on take me
yeah
think those birds and friend into place
and that's what's called flexing so
we're going to use a natural language
template to actually take those words
put into the sentence that I described
and that's flexing and then once you
know that sentence you can render the
different ways missed out so this is
that's kind of like the most abstract
and it might get here but this is sort
of the model for how we use language so
so before I move over into
implementation sign talk about whole and
it's kind of maybe will attract with
what Plateau why would we do this right
and so the idea here is the safety thing
is really really relevant in in knowing
and when we start applying the data
science ideas that policy in healthcare
so this is an article that you know I'm
actually just last month actually in the
bridge and kind of in no way made you
say okay what happened to the algorithm
cuts your healthcare I think most of us
you're right algorithms every day sort
of more than one type of algorithm the
sound to be a black box algorithm policy
optimization algorithm that was
installed in the state of Missouri was
using optimize their health plans when
end up doing was basically coming to
help having some limits on the the
allowable health care for something with
certain policy which wasn't intended but
just you know without bending it in
ketchup and then the person who actually
want to get services basically on the
area and in the news so then well we
will have to change it to get around you
want to make it so that you want to make
it something other than actually protect
you from having your policy on semantics
in the system you build an
interpretation nuts
so yeah so as I mentioned basically what
we have is a regulation of destiny the
collection of policy together is
extremely critical for our business and
also for them for the people that we
cover prior and we wanted to build a
system of policy management system that
not only check their checkboxes inventor
safety reliability and expressivity but
we also wanted to make the system
friendly for our subject matter experts
we wanted something that was useful so
on one hand we have you know this very
ambitious goal and when a system to
which you can describe the health
insurance plan that you want and somehow
the system administered to plan fully
automatically and doesn't make any
errors on the other hand we have a
server the subject matter experts I
already know how this have insurance
plan should work friend
so another perspective it makes sense to
have high bandwidth interface between
these 20s right you don't want to put
friction in the process of ingesting
expert knowledge into your system so
that is basically what one of the most
important things we were trying to look
here and as I said mention the approach
has been trying to fix you for to reach
this ultimate goal is come today we're
gonna somehow train a model with a bunch
of examples and some how the model is
when I perfectly understand all these
policies but rather we want to build a
system that will act as a intellectual
amplifier source for our subject matter
experts so I guess the point I'm trying
to make sure is you submitting was
extremely important we wanted to ingest
that the expert knowledge into a system
so from this user perspective and we our
goal semantics we need to answer for
which I first however power our experts
call entered into the system
you know how if you
how is it going to be and what types of
data can they enter into the into the
system second one of the data has been
entered into the front and how do we
justify we massage it into a format that
we can be useful things with third we
knew that maybe we want to have quality
control and safety checks on this data
we need some sort of version control
system so how are we gonna interact with
the version control system and finally
finally how how is the peer review
process for our how is that workflow
gonna look like from n to n now this
change usability was one of our main
goals you said it's not something that
you can just sit down analyst improve
right the way to verify if your system
is yourself your knowledge you need to
put something in front of people and see
if they actually can learn how to use
your MVC successfully accomplish their
goals so we wanted to be an MEP put
something in front people as fast as we
can and learn if it is something that
people can get can use to minister or
Twitter or bigger good so I'm gonna next
section first is going to be about
around these four questions so know well
how do we capture data and Gucci's
wasn't great mr. stern I has a great
very well documented API it's real and
it's reasonably fast pretty much every
single one of our subject matter experts
uses a cheat for a spreadsheet after him
at least once a day and we've had tables
of there are two extremely for
non-technical folks and they also really
dance so you know it has a nice
combination of having a nice information
density we understand again confusing
and finally with with you know we knew
this tournament would be a color
representation which is weak
people's use of an interface but I guess
some feature that come from free for
example cell color a drop-down
validation and so on that we could get a
pretty far in terms of use of enjoy next
okay so now we have this data in a
tabular format as well the left hand
side imaginary restraint shown so how do
we see realize how do we just that and
it is well if you think about what a
spreadsheet is is just an agreed upon
this branch and in each each cell in
this bridge as a coordinate associate so
what you want to show you want to map
the coordinate of each cell to the path
in the final serialize option so let's
say the other so the purpose of the mask
and one of the next things automatically
unless you go back for this you know
with the map you can go in both
directions and what we found is that if
our mask off one of the great structure
of the input for our subject matter
experts could actually maintain the mask
by themselves with just a little bit of
training and what we did on our intimate
we will code to make sure the Jason was
still compatible with a mask the front
end was compatible with a mask but all
you know let's say our expert wanted to
capture a new type of data plans it was
very easy for them to just any I'm gonna
fame of here in this part of the UI and
I'm gonna up treat the bus a little bit
and then if they get right the the favor
we tell okay I understand what you mean
I know how to adjust this data if they
provide something cool now the next
thing is version control so I guess the
main question other than they probably
have early my question attractive answer
early on is well should we build our own
solution or should we use an existing of
the shelf a version control system and
I'm sure you guys
this open source control system get
order to depart from reliable but there
are some very complicated right after
I'm showing that the key to data model
with all the pollution and pools and the
commits and so on the branches and
emerging and well not so you know that
was a million challenged from if we
decide to go down that path we also
discovered that if you want to be on the
distributed version control systems I
know many people to anything the same
time it's actually there's not many
shortcuts you can take to build up so
our solution has to take it and to and
to wrap it in an interface that's that
is accessible for our end-users so
basically we were able to condense all
of it complexity get it before commands
so we initialized up the of the command
that will create the branch and switch
to that branch edit is the thing that
will take the data from the git branch
into the UI request review would think
beating up from the UI check it through
the branch sinker the branch with master
and check for complex and in create a
full request and then finally clean up
command will just delete the local copy
of the repo and and it will delete your
branch
so that's person control so - so I guess
used to reiterate
so you know what normally we do speak up
after the virtual transformation with
you so without the producer with me
we're going to get up to as a version
control back end for the anything in
front and I said well that is coaches
and then for tecnológica we found a
pattern was a previous solution we're
only has libraries for the public safety
lines and you know it's pretty well
understood being in our company so
that's basically the core of
implementation issues
a new project that connects these two
systems and for each other
the actual two looks fine so the way the
program works is led by one to make a
change let's say I want to make a change
to plan ahead of cloud of iPads first in
a live inside one double clicked
initialize commander at the top and I
navigated to play the X then plan a and
then I double click Edit from there and
then finally when I'm done making my
changes now maybe I changed our plans
for whatever the other day I just go one
and the other from the request review
comment and we'll have a demo that you
know in a few moments now the thing is
I'm gonna talk about before the demo as
well as a periodic process work so we've
had a disk of actually you know was not
a pretty good foundation for the MVP so
first of all that the pull request you
is a very nice way for people to
communicate to exchange messages between
each among each other on a particular
change so you can do know a comment and
type or review for pull requests or you
can also add comments in line in a
particular piece of data and again what
about this on you forget about this the
other thing that we got for free was the
deep view on github so we found you know
if we made our serialize format
understandable we were able to just
present people they give you and they
understand what's going on
so people are know if our users are
expected to directly touch or directly
edit as you realize data but it still
understandable and that's how we are
able to to just use the copy for work
purposes and finally the other thing
that's pretty easy to do from github is
you know
there's the wrong change or you realize
I made a mistake it's very easy to roll
back anesthetic it's also very easy to
understand well you know when was this
every Tues and then finally in memory
you wanna understand the context like
who made it who controls the other
whoever of us also you know you can
relax you can visit the blank picture so
what's next is a little demo of the of
this framework basically despatches we
have a repo with our policy data
selecting it not only the master branch
and let's say i want to make a change so
the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go and run the initial man so
behind the scenes is train and clone to
my phone to my lack of you consider
that's coming the repo and it's grating
of - if arbitrage knowledge for branch
cut my username has a timestamp it's not
happening behind the scenes I'm gonna
edit this object called SPD started
going to the auction tt be edit command
and I'm gonna be presented with a with a
UI to make yes so let's say the future
it's a table and some sort of sentences
about health insurance policies is one
restrict the fertility medications so I
just copy the money from one side to
another
that's it that's the extent of my church
and started God do I want the requests
from your command
is his checking my changes in terminal
branch seeking master fader and then
bringing of the pull request via with
her I briefly describe what my changes
about under the totalcopies helpful
review message to the clipboard
respective and attack of the URLs in
case people consider for context of my
changes and then I just click the green
for required column the reviewer comes
in and then you say no and they say okay
whether you change and leads writer
that's a deep red okay consume a PC for
sweetness
change to open to this perspective and
then here I mean is everywhere in saying
okay
Ali Ali I approve this changes so it's
just right okay
acceptance message and then it's merging
and the changes so this one member
actually merged if I go back to the
ranch view get come you'll see that it
says okay that is branch that we merge
and then they get interested okay I'm
done I'm gonna do from the clean up
command and this is going to be meet my
local computer of their repo I just
needed my deleting my Bradshaw it's fun
and now we are about step one and the
structure has been updated so that's
that's the demo okay so this is
something we need build and we could use
this hand so what were they we found you
know like that did you saw was
sufficient for production use ground
scale this year
so now down here I have the utilization
data for the tool we were singing about
we saw our to 15 foot requests in four
months that's how three requests per day
per weekday so every day that people
came into the obvious our policy experts
Kenny to the offense
we saw three pull requests from the team
and that total self about four hundred
thousand data points and you know I
think this being simply tree will
receive we're actually able to just
strip out on the planet of the specific
module and in understory to I generalize
library to control different types of
business rules and other types of policy
information so what we'll learn number
one de you know much pressure controller
pressure control concepts actually
important to Muslim program you know
with the any of a differentiable fooling
myself that's really important to very
early on explain however she wants what
works and to introduce concepts that the
concepts in a way that that our users
would understand so for example we use a
term working copy we didn't talk about
and pools in whatever say there's a
working copy as your little sandbox very
special changes and when you're done
just request a review and we found the
people already knew but that B was so we
just attractive so very important to get
a clear early on we learn is that it was
a cheatin to the friends must be one
received by our users so we didn't
assembly trailer a huge or indigenous
and constructive deviation from the
works of the director there were your
studio stuff it is no big battle when
you're done and also with other people
really understood what was the point of
its right like that the comment that
comments that week and it's like well I
can't believe we ever lived without this
you know it didn't it didn't take long
for them to eternalize why this safe
workflow made sense to handle this
better data then finally the other thing
we observe is data versus conflicts for
clear air in our case and that has to do
in part because of the way we with match
plan data is officially one person
managing a super plan and also the way
we structure the plans in the repo where
one plan is set up those friend files so
you will get a harsh conflict and in the
case that two people touch the same part
of the plan at the same time and we only
actually write to turn those cases and
we found that for our MVP will need to
build robust and friendly merge conflict
resolution so completion so what one can
look back to the concept that Accenture
as if introduced and well you know in in
healthcare and there's this notion of
robotic process automation that the
state-of-the-art
everybody wants to you know automate it
means the negative sign of healthcare
and you know that sir
we don't think we can take this kind of
language testing approach and really
take this thing of relation to the next
level and I don't think we're actually
pretty close to to where this can become
a reality even if you think about this
lets you speak about the table where we
describe what a health insurance plan is
or well exactly what plan might want you
think about one particular cell in that
table there's a very well defined
context around that around that cell
right there's only a handful of messages
that make sense to enter in that cell
I'm gonna write a meeting with our
colleague or say thanks for whatever
they're like a very precise context that
means you know that there's only a
handful of messages that make sense and
that simplifies begin the language
processing part
the other thing that we found is like we
don't think this is an approach that can
be extensible you know it's very easy
for us to cook validation
recommendations automatic testing into a
system and generally from that program
this dissolute software pattern to
commit into the future and finally it is
shown that you know we're adding all of
these extra steps and parsing engine and
understanding of what's going on there
so you know that the system for sugar
more complicated path we think we do
necessary make it more brittle because
we're able to add our checking
validation and transportation section is
not a black box as you storing the data
in in a way that makes sense for subject
matter experts oh and that's somehow
thank you
questions all right 15 interruptions
before we did you refer nothing
very excited because we have a bajillion
different versions of contracts design
books easily processing to interpret
these contracts instead of how people
eyeballs on them on having to
immediately believe and and so yeah what
was the time and how long did it take
you to on this process yeah yes so why
it was I think this this whole thing
probably took place in a number of steps
over maybe and that's and then the
apartment that would dominate you saw it
was pretty quick
you